okay here we go
um eric portis and today i'll be
speaking on
low self-esteem and for me um
it was a driving force in my life and
it drove me man just like my addiction
did when i was um
hooked on the crack and um
it was like my little experience when um
my 30 attempts at uh
get my life together and it it drove me
like
the times where i just couldn't keep my
black ass up out of prison i was those
19 times
and um low self-esteem it goes hand in
hand with self-deception and uh
self-hatred you know and for me low
self-esteem man that stems from
growing up being in an area being a kid
and having all these examples around you
mind you you know coming from a single
parent background
i had some good information i have some
morals that have some values instilled
in me and all that kind of stuff and
outside of the family situation you know
i got some some
some misinformation you know some some
stuff that didn't serve a purpose
you know and um
the low self-esteem was was right in the
middle
of it all you know i knew my morals and
values from what my mom taught me
because i come from a single-parent
background
and then i knew the streets i knew the
hustle and the bustle and all that
[ __ ] because of my cousin
and my brother you know from the street
life and all that kind of stuff
and plus all the things that were going
on at that time of my life man
and um so on the outside i'm like hip
hip hooray everything's
good man you know i'm a kid man [ __ ]
let's go to disneyland you know
you know i'm gonna go to disneyland and
kick my feet and stuff like that
you know but in the inside man it was
something else entirely
i remember being a kid and being up all
night tossing and turning
because some [ __ ] was going on in my
mind man that i just couldn't handle
and it started around maybe nine or ten
years old
feeling like i just didn't belong man i
just i just wasn't worth it man
i'm like what the [ __ ] you know how do i
end up hearing this in this feeling in
this emotion
as a youngster got all these things
going on inside of me
and for the life of me man i couldn't
tell nobody what was really going on
what i was feeling because i didn't
understand at the time what it was
i had no inkling no idea
that i suffered from low self-esteem man
self-worth low self-worth
you know just because of the environment
that i was in just because of my
household arrangement
just because of my living situation you
know my relationships with people
that's what brought that [ __ ] on
and boy did it come with a forest man
and it drove me
and it drove me for over 20
years so i'm wondering why
why in the [ __ ] am i get i'm just going
back and forth to prison trip after trip
i say because with some self-worth
some self-respect then ain't no way in
the world i'ma do anything to put myself
in harm's way man no shape form of
fashion
ain't no way in hell i'm gonna put
myself in in danger
let alone go to prison 19 times back to
back to back the [ __ ] back
and what you call that i didn't know
what it was back then but i see now was
low self-worth because i didn't give a
[ __ ] about myself
but i couldn't tell you that i couldn't
even tell myself that because i didn't
know it at the time
i'm thinking i'm just going through the
motions so everybody in the neighborhood
goes to prison
or everybody in the neighborhood is
getting get hooked on crack that's a
[ __ ] lie
everybody don't and you don't have to
i was just one of those unfortunate ones
that had to go through that
but you can best believe that that low
self-esteem and that low self-worth that
[ __ ] was a
was a motivating factor
for me getting involved in everything
man that i wasn't supposed to do
that everything that i wasn't
supposed to experience that's exactly
what i did
because i didn't know man i just didn't
care i didn't care about me i didn't
give a [ __ ] what you thought what you
feel
none of that stuff man and the cool
thing about it is i remember being a
rebellious teenager
so i'll go back to maybe
uh maybe 12 years old
and um as an example
i wanted to go to this house party
around the corner because all my friends
was going to be there
and my mom said that i couldn't you know
i couldn't attend a little party that
that night so what i did i waited till
she went to sleep
i climbed my black ass about the window
and i snuck and i went around the corner
and had the time of my life
when i came back home i convinced to get
my ass whipped
and right after that man the next day i
ran away
i'ma show your ass you hurt me i'mma
hurt you back in my own way
it wasn't to hurt her
i just didn't give a damn it didn't
matter to me
i didn't give a [ __ ] what happened to me
where i ended up at
same with experience experiment with
drugs and alcohol man i didn't care what
the [ __ ] it was man i
you know my thing my code of honor back
then was man i'll try
i'll try anything just once and i did
for the most part
there's only a few things i didn't get
to try substances
you know um lsd nah
uh xtc yeah but for the most part
i had my feel
and um it was all just to cover up that
feeling you know just to cover up that
feeling man
you know those emotions man that i just
couldn't identify with i just couldn't
put a
put a finger on i will overstitch or or
stab
you know so from nine years old up until
through my teens
man that [ __ ] was a driving force where
i just did every and anything
man not to be me just escape escape that
feeling man because for the life of me i
couldn't talk about it to nobody
and then he got some more [ __ ] added on
to it because of the
the direct result of the drugs
he come to [ __ ] self-deception here
comes the self-hatred
it's the most [ __ ] that i had to add to
the equation and now i feel like i'm
[ __ ] i'm in a volcano
and it's erupting and that [ __ ] is
boiling over but i'm stuck at the bottom
of it just boiling
disintegrating burning just burning my
flesh alive from the inside out
that's what it felt like dying slowly
without no [ __ ] rescue in sight
couldn't see it feelings and emotions
and they're subject to change but these
[ __ ] stayed with me for years
the self-worth that stayed with me for a
long
time right there's like my [ __ ]
shadow wake up in the morning there it
is talking to me
like what the where does feeling come
from why oh it's a beautiful day outside
but i've got this this dark cloud
hovering over me
i'm like [ __ ] when it rains it pours man
i'm like where does this come from it's
not raining and it's a beautiful day
but it's that feeling that consumes me
man
and it drives me so when i want to when
i'm supposed to do right
that's what i do i do the opposite i do
wrong my mom say here here's 10 bucks
man
go get some milk and bread from the
store
keep the change
okay mom i can do that be right back
man she won't see me for about two weeks
cause i take that 10 [ __ ] dollars and
i'm supposed to go get something for the
household go to the [ __ ] neighborhood
crack house
and commence the smoke knowing
knowing the consequences of that
knowing i won't be trusted knowing i
won't be let back in the house
no one add on to some [ __ ] from my
brother and my sister and all that kind
of stuff oh he then did it again
you got to be [ __ ] you got to be
kidding me
mom not again that's the kind of [ __ ] i
was on
and it happened on a regular basis in
different shapes
in different fashions i wasn't playing
i seriously might think about committing
suicide
it's just i was just thinking oh i was
hoping at the time
that it occurred faster than the way it
was happening because
my suicide was like okay i'm going to
get a 20
crack rock i'm gonna put the whole thing
on the pipe and take one big ass
hit and try to bust my [ __ ]
chest
that was the way i saw it but it didn't
turn off that way
oh i took the big ass head
[ __ ] couldn't and and and and and and
got a [ __ ]
uh brain shocking and pass out on the
ground
i remember one time scared me to death
but not enough to stop me i was in the f
i was in the alley
and i was squatting down and i squatted
took me a big ass [ __ ] hit and
then you know what now
mind you it's about 12 noon and i'm on
the side of this dumpster this trash can
and i woke up sprawled out in the middle
of the alley man
and when i came to i'm [ __ ] looking
up
and it's dark and i'm like where am i
because i'm looking at these big
old cypress trees and everything
and i must have laid in that alley
unconscious maybe for a few hours
it was all it wasn't dork but it was
late in the evening because i i remember
the difference in the temperature
from when i took that hit it was nice
and sunny when i woke my ass up it was
it was breezy it was windy
and um scared me to death because i was
thinking man somebody could have walked
through this alley and saw me man it
just hurt me real bad
and that was a reality shock for a
minute but then it wore off
and here i have to go again with some
more [ __ ] deadly experiences
playing with some [ __ ] playing with fire
throwing rocks at the penitentiary
you know because i just didn't know how
to deal with man deal with what
was the truth at the time true for us
man i feel like a piece of [ __ ] man
i just didn't belong man i feel like i
just didn't fit in
i don't give a [ __ ] if i was more into a
rich family i probably would have had
those same feelings and emotions
they didn't mean because i was black
poor in real trouble they ain't got [ __ ]
to do with it man
because there was a lot of good times i
had a lot of good experiences a lot of
good memories it wasn't all bad
it was just that feeling i just couldn't
i couldn't
i just didn't know how to deal with it
so that's the driving force
that led me left when i should have went
right every time
it was a part of my character makeup
by the time i hit my 20s and
i knew what it was by then
i know exactly what that feeling was
because i've been dealing with it for so
long
because during those those late teens
going into my 20s
i said well let me try to get my [ __ ]
together let me try to get myself
together
and stop doing because the way i was
headed and my experiences were going to
prison
because by time i was 18 i already
i had three stints in the county jail
before i was 18.
so by time i hit 18 i was up i mean i
was in uh uh the state penitentiary
you know and um came home and went right
back
at uh 20 and i stayed going to like 22
almost 23 years old you know i did 16
would have like 10 months
stayed home maybe six months and went
right back for four years
so they gave me about 27 months to go
two years
right before you know it
you know now mind you i went to fire
camp
so my experience in in in prison man it
was like
[ __ ] adventure i just couldn't
believe it man
you know so i went in scrawny and skinny
and um came out man looking like um lou
ferrigno
you know an incredible hulk and that's
what i felt like
but here on the back on the back end man
that feeling was with me too
you know but it just wasn't strong
enough to make me want to mess up
immediately after i came home because i
want to try something different
so that's when i began to recognize it
for what it was
low self-esteem and some most [ __ ] added
to it that
that that i added to the equation by my
experiences we're doing wrong we're
doing bad things in the people
you know picking up those bad habits and
all that kind of stuff because you pick
them up along the way i know i do
and i cured them i carried them you know
like my backpack for years you know on
my shoulders man and it was heavier than
a [ __ ]
i'm talking about heavy murder some
terms of
touring through the day you know i feel
like the um
the israelites in in in in the
wilderness for 40 years
you know because i just couldn't see no
relief of sight in my neighborhood
because there was always something going
on in the neighborhood and it wasn't
good you know
it wasn't all bad but god damn
something she was like man can this [ __ ]
just go ahead and blow over or just pass
by now
but it seemed like year after year after
year after year things got a little bit
worse in the neighborhood crack became
more epidemic
crack houses appeared more despair
came depression
some [ __ ] i wasn't even ready for i had
no idea
but it was all going on and it was
happening in my neighborhood right
before my eyes man
and i'm like oh my god what is this
[ __ ] ain't no way in the hell i'm gonna
get off some damn crap
because you had a crack house in every
other house man
it's like they have the liquor stores on
every corner in the church
side by side competing with each other
for your [ __ ] soul
now ain't that some [ __ ]
got all these churches in the
neighborhood man it's like a thousand of
them in a six block radius man
competing but i didn't see them out
there
coming to the crack house coming to the
alleyways and the byways
talking and trying to get you you know
you had to go there
and i'm like man if i have to go to your
ass i'm good
[ __ ] i need you all here where
i'm at meet me somewhere in the middle
[ __ ] come by passing off some flowers or
something and we're talking you say well
meet me at church or something
i think you i think you um think i can
help you you know
then i would have did it man gladly
so i had a resentment against the
churches in the neighborhood because
every time i'm going to and fro from
hustling
from stealing and robbing or going
coming coming and going from the crack
house
you know i'm looking at the churches man
i'm looking at the cross and all that
the protestants and the catholics and
and the
espionages whatever that is and um
i'm like wow man all these different
organizations all these different names
man baptist and all that kind of stuff
and um i said when i finally come around
i want to do something
non-denominational
because i don't want to claim nothing
when it comes to religion you know
because i grew up
it was all in the neighborhood man but i
didn't see them
it was always behind closed doors except
on sundays
and then when i walked my tired nasty
toe up ass by the church they wouldn't
let me up in there the way i was looking
or the way i was smelling
you know they shun me what the what you
want to come in here hell yeah i want to
come in here i'm tired [ __ ]
i want to rest my feet for a minute is
that okay with you sir
talking to the deacon oh i'm sorry man
but um yeah you can't um
yeah service is almost over once you try
back next sunday i know that
[ __ ] was lying to me
and i didn't blame him because if i
would see him if i was in issues i
probably would have said the same exact
thing you ain't getting your ass up in
here
lord knows you might go up in here and
take every [ __ ] thing that's
not well
down and he was probably right if i had
the opportunity
i know i wasn't gonna put no money in
the plate so if the plate passed by me
best believe i was gonna take something
off that plate and put it in my pocket
desperate didn't give a [ __ ]
give a [ __ ] about me care about my
future
my outlet man my [ __ ] was bleak
you know and um
so i just walked by to churches and on
sundays
sit outside and imagine what it'd be
like being on the other side crossing
that threshold
and going one sunday half ass clean
you know with a shower maybe some jeans
and a [ __ ] t-shirt or a tank top or
something
you know minus the ball cap
and um i didn't get to see that happen
in my 20s
you know but something else happened and
that was just me trying to get myself
together man going through the rehabs
and so the more i started doing the
self-realizations and all that kind of
stuff and
and the more information i got from
different people and all that kind of
stuff i said okay i can pinpoint
that feeling and emotion man that low
self-esteem man i said that's just been
a guiding force for me forever
i said something got to change man
something got that man something got to
happen
you know because it's ruling me you know
and it's taking me down these these
these highways and by ways man where
there's just man
it's only doom and gloom you know and
there's only three alternatives for me
man from my experiences
coming to the realization that the fact
was i end up in prison
i end up in rehabs or i end up homeless
by that guiding force those are my
my only three alternatives that i've had
you know dealing with that [ __ ] man
so i feel like i was really
in incredible in dire streets man
when um i say in my my mid-30s
when i said god damn i'm dealing with
self-deception
most definitely self-hatred most
definitely low self-esteem
low self-worth
i said now i thought the l word meant
for love
i don't know where this low [ __ ] came
from added to the words you know to the
equation
you know but there was no love in my it
wasn't no love in the picture i couldn't
even see it for me man
love me what like me you got to be
kidding me out your [ __ ] mind
get out of here with that [ __ ] that's
the first thing from the truth man i
might tell you that
i might tell you everything's fine and
all that kind of stuff and put up a good
fight
but deep inside man i didn't have it i
didn't have that fight i didn't have
that desire
you know it just overwhelmed me and i
gave in
every time i got a a hand deal to me to
get my [ __ ] together to get my life
together and i fold the cords
it had one up on me it went up because i
knew what it was it wasn't me
it was that feeling man it was that that
it was that man i knew what it was every
time i had an opportunity
to get to a program or to get my [ __ ]
together man
and and and i squandered that
opportunity i knew exactly what
what it was it didn't take no rocket
scientists
i've been in situations and positions
man where i had action man where god
sent those guardian angels down right
right then in the nick of time to help
me man
and um i would piss on it piss on an
opportunity
and let it go by and you can best
believe me somebody
more well deserving than me got that
opportunity and got that chance of a new
life and i'm pretty sure they got it i'm
pretty sure they're living today beyond
their wildest dreams
because that's how i am today i feel it
it just took me a long time to get it
you know but everybody gets a turn
i had many chances i had many terms
you know so it's not easy
you know but it's it's it's not easy
but the thing that kind of stopped me
man and it kept me
kept me um like in a strange record man
was was not denial
you know it wasn't the fact that that
that i didn't know what was going on
because i
did i just feel like i had no choice in
matter i had no say-so on the in this
matter
you know what can i do [ __ ] i'm only one
man i'm because it started as a child so
back then my excuse was oh what can i do
man i'm only a kid
i can't even identify what's going on
then when i got to the teenage years
it's like oh man come on man i'm just a
teenager man what you expect man robin
is stealing and
shooting [ __ ] and experimenting with all
that come on man come with the territory
and it did come with the territory to
some degree
it did well i was raised of course [ __ ]
in the ghetto
you're gonna try every [ __ ]
thing you know and um i did you know
everything that it had to offer
you know i was man i'm gonna be first in
line
for that but this
but when i got to my 20s
then i had to i couldn't use that excuse
no more oh man come on man i'm just a
kid man they come with the turret turn
all that [ __ ] because it didn't
because i saw where my life was going
man and i saw the turmoil i was in i saw
myself
in that big ass pout lost in the sauce
man i'm like i got to get up out of here
i can't last too much longer man being
stirred man
in this mixture [ __ ]
because i'm going deeper and deeper into
the pot man submerging man
it's gonna be hard for me to come from
under that because of the stuff that i
was adding on to it you know the
different
habits that i picked up you know
character traits from others
and um so in my mid-thirties i decided
to do something about it
and that's where the help came from and
i when people came and offered help i
took it
you damn right i did [ __ ]
i'm crazy but i'm not that crazy because
i was tired
sick and tired of being sick and tired
man out of [ __ ] but it's self-hatred
and all that [ __ ] to low self-esteem
man please i know i'm better than that
i've got to be
i noticed more to me than that even
though that was the driving force in my
life
i knew there was more to me than just
that i said well [ __ ] now
i'm looking at my all my liabilities
like what the [ __ ] are the assets what
are my assets at
what are the pros and cons when it comes
to me let me take a look
because it's been a long time man
because i was so stuck in that
in the [ __ ] i couldn't see anything
good
because i couldn't see the the pores
from the trees man
you know and i could be deep in the
valley or i can be on the mountain top
man
and it's i'll just be focusing on the
trees man instead of the horizon and
what's out there
overlooking the trees how beautiful is
the sunset and all that kind of stuff
for the color of the sky
aren't many clouds in the shape of the
clouds so i'm stuck on the [ __ ] trees
because i can't look up because i'm so
so busy looking down
because that was my life down [ __ ] i
didn't have no reason to hold my head up
high
straight back and all that [ __ ] with
a smile on my face welcoming
that wasn't me it wasn't bleak but god
damn that wasn't me
i didn't always look down but i see
eight out of ten times when i leave the
house and i'll
go i'm looking down you know and and got
some consumed by some [ __ ]
that i don't even notice that's just
driving me and guiding me
to these places unknown
you know that's a cold situation to be
and that's a cold life that you have to
endure man i had to endure that [ __ ] and
i had to go through it man
and i wouldn't wish that on nobody
on nobody not my worst enemy
thank god man i came to a place where i
just said man i can't take no more man i
give
up [ __ ] that [ __ ] i got to do
something because it starts with me and
it answered me just like the way it
started when i was a kid and couldn't
identify
as a as i got into adulthood and then i
saw for what it was i said well there's
something i can do about it
and that's where the effort came and i
had to put forth some kind of effort
so when people came and said hey man
would you like to do this yes sir
yes ma'am and that's where those 30
trips to
uh uh rehab came from
i tried that [ __ ] 30 times man i want i
want more than what this [ __ ] has to
offer me i want more than what this has
to offer me
and i wasn't playing took me 30 times to
get it
but she at least i know what i was
dealing with wasn't it
all about nothing
i know exactly what it was and it was
killing me
it has been killing me for the longest i
don't know how many years
at least i knew what it was finally
okay so that was my starting place
i thank god for creating me the way he
has
because i'm not a quitter i'm a fighter
now i might have fought the wrong fight
over the years and fighting for the
wrong
the wrong cause you know because um
i was a hell of a [ __ ] hustler out
there on the streets man when i was out
there in that lifestyle man
i was somebody to be reckoned with but i
wasn't playing out there man
when i was hustling and bustling and all
that kind of stuff when i was smoking
that crack man and
him to get that [ __ ] whoa i was a force
to be reckoned with
so i said well let's try to flip this
flip the script on this and see if i can
be a force to be recording something
good
something positive and um
those are those are my goals today you
know what can i contribute what can i
add to the creation today
you know good you know something
positive
you know so that keeps me from going
backwards into that doom and gloom and
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
low self-esteem and self-earth i don't
buy that [ __ ] no more
you can't sell it to me take that [ __ ]
somewhere else to somebody else who
don't know no better
i do so when it comes to dealing with
individuals
men and women and i see it in them i
talk to them and i share some stuff but
if they ain't trying to get up out of it
i'm gone because i don't want that [ __ ]
jumping jumping back on me because i
know how long i had to carry mine around
before i was finally free so if somebody
else has it and i see it for what it is
because it's me i see i see you and me
and i share some stuff about it and you
take no heat i said oh [ __ ] that was me
in my 30s
i was just the same uh yeah i was the
same way when so-and-so tried to talk to
me
i did the same reaction i said the same
[ __ ] exact thing you got to be
kidding me
deja vu you know
and um so thank god that i can see it
for what it is
and that i can help too in times of need
if i can man i put it out there
and i let them know [ __ ] you're not
alone and you probably don't have to go
through it as long as i did
you know for some reason people like me
go through some [ __ ] man and it's just
you know i
i can't i can't even put a name on it
man that's not i'm that's not my place
to speak on somebody else's experience
but i know there's a lot of people like
me who's who's
whose trials and tribulations are
exactly the same man assembler
and i'm talking about for the men and
women you know it's just
man i just have to see it for what it
was man
you know i can't blame it on the
neighborhood i can't blame it on the
upbringing i can't blame it on being
poor i can't blame it on being black man
god damn man i got to see it for what it
is you know those are valid excuses
anybody added to it but that's not
that's not the um
that's not the foundation you know that
it's based on
you know it's based on me having fears
you know human nature
you know and i just let my human nature
um
you know impose their will on me man
when it came to that
the negative instincts instead of the
natural instincts you know my natural
instincts to get up to go to school to
do good and all that kind of [ __ ]
but the the bad nature part of the flip
side of it was man
like i said before a driving force in my
life
and i'm just glad that i'm finally out
that
that roller coaster ride i want to share
something man before i close
i remember being
in the crack house one time
i think i had a thousand dollars
i had just got finished doing the scene
and um i went to the [ __ ] crack house
got some stuff
i said now i better go to the motel for
this for this experiment that i'm gonna
do
so um i gotta run for two hours and i
said i'm gonna smoke for the whole two
hours
until it's time to leave and whatever i
have left i'm just gonna hide it
you know or flush it or whatever i know
damn well i wouldn't flush it i think i
ended up taking it with me after the
chores up whatever i didn't finish but
i remember i said every time i blow the
smoke out i'ma feel like i'm on a roller
coaster ride and i'm gonna close my eyes
and when i blow the smoke and i'm gonna
act like i'm on this ride
and i think i must have closed my eyes a
thousand times in that two hours man
that i was in that room
and you know before the end of the
experiment when i took a hit off the
[ __ ] crack pipe and closed my eyes
and blew the smoke out
i got the weave and i got the ducking
and all that like i was hitting all the
turns because on the right when it was
going to dip
on the right one it was going to go up
and the right one was going to go left
the only one was going to turn right to
sharp turn
and i had that whole experience that
ride
man [ __ ] that ride that's the right man
i don't want to take man cause i was on
that ride for many
many years i was wonderful like me man
why can't i get off this damn roller
coaster ride man
but every time no matter where i was at
i took a hit
off the crack pipe and blow off the
smoke i might not get it to experiment
but that's exactly what it felt like
like i was on a roller coaster ride
and on all the dips and turns i don't
care where i was at
and i came full circle
with low self-esteem because it was one
day i'm up
one day i'm down one day i'm up high low
and out all these turns and all that
kind of stuff and twist to it
i just had to slow down long enough to
get my take in on it and see it for what
it was
and my best teacher was my life
experience man you know all the places
i've traveled all the roads i've been on
and all the places i've been
you know the things i've done that kind
of showed me that gave me that road map
and i said okay i see clearly now
what's going on and um that's my saving
grace
having the courage man
to see it for what it is and do the best
i can to work with it
and try to overcome it get to the other
side because i know wherever there's a
lesson that i learn
then there's a blessing coming right
behind it every time
i drop a bad character trait or a bad
habit and try something different
there's
always something good that follows
always an open door
i never dropped a bad habit or or or a
bad vice
and then and encountered a closed door
and i mean uh open doors this
opportunity that's all it means to me
always an open door so behind every
lesson that i learned man
there's a blessing believe that cause i
do
wholeheartedly
it's not easy but it's not hard today
for me
getting through some [ __ ] learning some
more stuff
staying open to anything good keeping my
eyes and my mind open to any new and all
information
because it helps me it doesn't hurt me
i'll try
anything that helps man anything that's
a healing process
i'm with that you know and since i'm
staying by myself and i do my own thing
so at home man i
i clean man i love cleaning and i love
listening to my music
and i love my punk rock you know
get to the bathroom i was i was at right
before coming here man i did my bathroom
i was in there for maybe an hour 45
minutes in the shower man love my music
the music just that's my driving force
today
that's what drives me
thank god i got to that side good thank
god i get to see that for what it is
because that's a beautiful thing for me
you mean that's what
yeah that's what drives me and i don't
have to be hurt behind it i don't have
to hurt nobody behind i have to end up
in prison and all that other madness
that come with it
this feeling this emotion you got to be
[ __ ] me no i'm not
that's the guy's honest truth
because there was a time in my life
where i couldn't live with or without me
man
[Music]
but now i wouldn't want it any other way
and that's the truth doctor wrote thank
you
you